YUFEI ZHAO: All right.
Last time we started talking
about pseudorandom graphs,
and we considered this theorem
of Chung, Graham, and Wilson,
which, for dense graphs, gave
several equivalent notions
of quasi-randomness that,
at least the phase values,
do not appear to be
all that equivalent.
But they are actually-- you
can deduce one from the other.
There was one condition
at the very end which
had to do with eigenvalues.
And, basically, it said that if
your second largest eigenvalue
in absolute value is small,
then the graph is pseudorandom.
So that's something that I
want to explore further today
to better understand
the relationship
between eigenvalues of a
graph and the pseudorandomness
properties.
For much of-- pretty
much all of today,
we're going to look at a
special class of graphs
known as n, d, lambda graphs.
This just means we
have n vertices,
and we're only going
to consider, mostly
out of convenience,
d regular graphs.
So this will make our
life somewhat simpler.
And the lambda stands for that--
if you look at the
adjacency matrix,
and if you write
down the eigenvalues
of the adjacency
matrix, then, well,
what are these eigenvalues?
The top one, because it's
d regular, is equal to d.
And lambda corresponds
to the statement
that all the other
eigenvalues are, at most,
lambda in absolute value.
So the top one is equal to d.
All the other ones
in absolute value--
so it could be basically
the maximum of these two--
is bounded above by lambda.
And at the end of last time,
we showed this expander
mixing lemma, which, in this
language, says that if G is n,
d, lambda, then one has the
following discrepancy type.
So the randomness
property, namely
that if you look
at two vertex sets
and look at how many actual
edges are between them compared
to what you expect if
this were a random graph
of a similar density, then these
two numbers are very similar,
and the amount of error is
controlled by your lambda.
In particular, a smaller lambda
gives you a more pseudorandom
graph.
So the second part
of today's class,
I want to explore
the question of how
small this lambda can be.
So what's the optimal
amount of pseudorandomness?
But, first, I want to
show you some examples.
So, so far, we've been talking
about pseudorandom graphs,
and the only
example, really, I've
talked about is that a
random graph is pseudorandom.
Which is true.
A random graph is pseudorandom
with high probability,
but some of the spirit
of pseudorandomness
is to come up with
non-random examples, come up
with deterministic
constructions that give you
pseudorandom properties.
So I want to begin
today with an example.
A lot of examples, especially
for pseudorandomness,
come from this class of
graphs called Cayley graphs,
which are built from a group.
So we're going to reserve the
letter G for graphs, so I'm
going to use gamma for a group.
And I have a subset S of
gamma, and S is symmetric,
in that if you invert
the elements of S,
they remain in S.
Then we define the Cayley
graph given by this group
and the set S to be
the following graph,
where V, the set of vertices, is
just the set of group elements.
And the edges are obtained
by taking a group element
and multiplying it by S
to go to its neighbor.
So this is a Cayley graph.
And Cayley graphs are--
start with any group, start
with any subset of the group,
you get a Cayley graph.
And this is a very important
construction of graphs.
They have lots of
nice properties
And, in particular, an
example of a Cayley graph
is a Paley graph.
They're not related.
So a Paley graph
is a special case
of a Cayley graph
obtained by considering
the group, the cyclic group mod
p, where p is prime 1 mod 4.
And I'm looking at S being the
set of quadratic residues, mod
p.
It's actually nonzero
quadratic residues.
So elements of mod p
that could be a square.
So we will show in a second
that this Paley graph has
nice pseudorandom
properties by showing
that it is an n, d, lambda
graph with lambda fairly small
compared to the degree.
Just a historical note--
so Raymond Paley-- so the
Paley graph named after him--
he actually-- he was from the
earlier part of 20th century.
So from 1907 to 1932.
So he died very young
at the age of 26,
and he actually
died in an avalanche
when he was skiing
by himself in Banff.
So Banff is a national
park in Alberta in Canada.
And when I was in Banff
earlier this year for a math
conference-- so there's also a
math conference center there--
so I had a chance
to go visit the--
Raymond Paley's tomb.
So there's a graveyard there
where you can find his tomb.
And it's very sad that, in his
short mathematical timespan,
actually he managed to do a
lot of amazing mathematical--
find a lot of amazing
mathematical discoveries.
And there are many important
concepts named after him.
So things like Paley-Wiener
theorem, Paley-Zygmund,
Littlewood-Paley, all this
important ideas and analysis
named after Paley.
And Paley graph is also
one of his contributions.
So what we'll claim is that
this Paley graph has the desired
pseudorandom properties, in that
if you look at its eigenvalues,
then the top
eigenvalues, except--
so except for the
top eigenvalue,
all the other eigenvalue
are quite small.
So keep in mind
that the size of S
is basically half of the group.
So p minus 1 over 2.
So for especially
larger values of p,
p's eigenvalues are quite
small compared to the degree.
So the main way to
show that Cayley graphs
like that have small
eigenvalues is to just compute
what the eigenvalues are.
And this is actually not so hard
to do for Cayley graphs, so let
me do this explicitly.
So I will tell you
very explicitly a set
of eigenvectors.
And they are-- the
first eigenvector
is just the all 1's vector.
The second eigenvector
is the vector
coming from 1,
omega, omega squared,
so omega to the p
minus 1, where omega
is a parameter of
p-th root of unity.
The next one is 1, omega
square, omega fourth,
all the way to omega p--
omega to the 2 times p minus 1.
And so on.
So I want to have--
yes, so OK.
So I make this list,
and I have p of them.
So these are my eigenvectors.
And let me check that they
are actually eigenvectors.
And then we can also
compute their eigenvalues.
So the top eigenvector
corresponds to d.
So the all 1's in
a d regular graph
is always an eigenvector
with eigenvalue d.
And the other ones, we'll
just do this computation.
So instead of getting
confused with indices,
let me just compute,
as an example,
the j-th coordinate of the
adjacency matrix times V2.
So the j-th coordinate,
so what it comes to,
is the following sum.
If I run over S, then
omega raised to j plus s.
So S is symmetric, so I don't
have to worry so much about
plus or minus.
So I say j plus s.
So if you think about what
this Cayley graph, how
it is defined, if you hit
this vector with that matrix,
the j-th coordinate
is that sum there.
But I can rewrite the sum by
taking out this common factor
omega to j.
And you see that this is
the j-th coordinate of V2.
And this is true for all j.
So this number here is lambda 2.
And, more generally, lambda
k is the following sum,
for k from 0--
so from k being 1 through p.
So when you plug in k
equals to 1, you just get d.
And the others are sums
of these exponential sums.
Now, this is a pretty
straightforward computation.
And, in fact, we're
not using anything
about quadratic residues.
This is a generic fact about
Cayley graphs of z mod p.
So this is true for all Cayley
graphs S, not necessarily
for quadratic residues.
And the basic reason
is that, here, you
have this set of eigenvectors,
and they do not depend on S.
So you might know this
concept from other places,
such as circular
matrices and whatnot,
but this is true in
this simple computation.
So now we have the values
of lambda explicitly.
I can now compute their sizes.
I want to know how
big this lambda is.
Well, the first one,
when k equals to 1,
it's exactly d, the degree,
which is p minus 1 over 2.
But what about the other ones?
So, for the other ones, we can
do a computation as follows.
So note that I can
rewrite lambda k
by noting that if
I take twice it
and plus 1, then I
obtain the following sum.
Because here I am using the S
as a set of quadratic residues.
So if I consider this sum
here, every quadratic residue
gets counted twice, except for
0, which gets counted once.
And now I would like to
evaluate the size of this sum,
this exponential sum.
And this is something
that's known as a Gauss sum.
So, basically, a
Gauss sum is what
happens when you
have something that's
like a quadratic, an exponential
sum with a quadratic dependence
in the exponent.
And the trick here is to
consider the square of the sum.
So the magnitude squared.
Now if I expand the square--
so squaring is a common
feature of many of the things
we do in this course.
It really simplifies your life.
You do the square,
you expand the sum.
You can re-parameterize one
of the summands like that.
So do two steps at once.
I'm re-parameterizing
and I'm expanding.
But now you see, if I expand
the exponent, we find--
so that's just algebra.
And now you notice that this
sum here, the sum over a
is equal to--
when b is nonzero, I
claim that this sum is 0.
And when b is nonzero, then I'm
summing over some permutations
of the roots of unity.
So here I'm assuming
that k is bigger than--
let's say here k is not 0.
So I'm re-parameterizing
k a little bit.
So k is not 0.
Then when b is not 0,
the sum over a is 0.
And otherwise it equals to p.
So the sum over
here equals to p.
And, therefore, lambda
k, lambda sub k--
how about if I--
so what should I change that to?
So if I-- k is 0, then I want
this to be lambda sub k plus 1.
Then lambda sub k plus
1 is equal to plus/minus
p plus 1 over 2, for all
lambda not equal to 0.
So, really, except for
the top eigenvalue,
which is just the degree,
all the other ones
are one of these two values,
and they're all quite small.
So this is an explicit
computation showing you
that this Paley graph is
indeed a pseudorandom graph.
It's an example of a
quasi-random graph.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we know
what the sign is?
YUFEI ZHAO: The question is,
do we know what the sign is?
So we actually--
so here I am not
telling you what the sign
is, but you can look up.
Actually, people have
computed exactly what
the sign should be.
And this is something that you
can find in a number theory
textbook, like Aaron and Rosen.
Any more questions?
There is a concept
here I just want
to bring out, that you might
recognize sums like this.
So this kind of sum.
That's a Fourier coefficient.
So if you have some
Fourier transform, I mean,
this is exactly what Fourier
transforms look like.
And it is indeed the
case that, in general,
if you have an Abelian
group, then the eigenvalues
and the spectral information of
the corresponding Cayley graph
corresponds to
Fourier coefficients.
And this is the connection
that we'll see also
later on in the course when we
consider additive combinatorics
and giving a Fourier analytic
proof of Roth's theorem.
And there Fourier analysis
will play a central role.
But this is actually-- this
analogy, as I've written it,
is only for Abelian groups.
If you try to do the same
for non-Abelian groups,
you will get something
somewhat different.
So for non-Abelian
groups, you do not
have this nice notion
of Fourier analysis,
at least in the versions
that generalizes what's
above in a straightforward way.
But, instead, you have something
else, which many of you
have seen before but
under a different name.
And that's representation
theory, which, in some sense,
is Fourier analysis,
except, instead
of one-dimensional objects
and complex numbers,
we're looking at
higher-dimensional
representations.
So I just want to point
out this connection,
and we'll see more
of it later on.
Any questions?
So let's talk more
about Cayley graphs.
So, last time, we
mentioned these notions
of quasi-randomness.
And I said at the
end of the class
that many of these equivalences
between quasi-random graphs,
they fail for sparse graphs.
If your density, if your
x density is a constant,
then the equivalences
no longer hold.
But what about
for Cayley graphs?
And, in particular, I
would like to consider
two specific notions that
we discussed last time
and try to understand how they
relate to each other for Cayley
graphs.
So for dense Cayley
graphs, it's a special case
of what we did yesterday.
So I'm really interested
in sparser Cayley graphs,
even down the degree.
So even down the degree.
So that's much sparser
than the regime
we were looking at last time.
And the main result
I want to tell you
is that the DISC condition
is, in a very strong sense,
actually equivalent to
the eigenvalue condition
for all Cayley graphs, including
non-Abelian Cayley graphs.
So before telling you
what the statement is,
I first want to give
an example showing you
that this equivalence
is definitely not true
if you remove the
assumption of Cayley graphs.
For example, if you--
so example that this is
false for non-Cayley.
Because if you take,
let's say, a large--
so let's say d regular graph.
So let's say a large
random d regular graph.
d here can be a constant
or growing with n,
but this is a pretty
robust example.
And then I add to it an extra
destroying copy of k sub d
plus 1 that's much smaller in
terms of number of vertices.
The big, large
random graph, well,
by virtue of being
a random graph,
has the discrepancy property.
And because we're only
adding in a very small number
of vertices, it does not destroy
the discrepancy property.
The discrepancy
property, if you're just
adding a small
number of vertices,
it doesn't change much.
So this whole thing
has discrepancy.
However, what about
the eigenvalues?
Claim that the top
two eigenvalues
are in fact both equal to d.
And that's because you have
two eigenvectors, one which
is the all 1's vector
on this graph, another
which is the all 1's
vector on that graph.
These two DISC components each
give you a top eigenvector
of d, so you get d twice.
And, in particular, the second
eigenvalue is not small.
So the implication from
DISC to eigenvalue really
fails for non-Cayley
graph for general graphs.
The implication, the other
direction is actually OK.
In fact, the eigenvalue implies
DISC is actually the content
of the expander mixing lemma.
So this follows by
expander mixing lemma.
And that's because, if you
look at the expander mixing
lemma for a Cayley graph--
or for a-- not for
Cayley graph-- for--
if you have the
eigenvalue condition,
then, automatically, you would
find that these two guys here
are at most n.
So if lambda is quite small
compared to the degree,
then you still have the desired
type of quasi-randomness.
So I'll make the statements
more precise in a second.
So the question is, how
can we certify, how can we
show that, in fact, DISC, which
is seemingly weaker property,
implies a stronger property of
eigenvalue for Cayley graphs.
And what is a special
about Cayley graphs that
would allow to do this, that
the statement is generally
false for non-Cayley graphs?
So let me define--
so let me first
tell you the result.
So this is the result
due to David Conlon
and myself two years ago.
So many of you may not have been
to many seminar talks, where
there's this convention
in mathematics talks
where you don't write out your
full name, only by the initial.
Although some kind
of false modesty.
But, of course, we all love
talking about our own results,
but somehow we
don't like to write
our own name for some reason.
So here's the theorem.
So I start with a
finite group, gamma.
And let me consider a subset
S of gamma that is symmetric.
And consider G the Cayley graph.
Let me right n as the number of
vertices, and d the size of S.
So this is a d regular graph.
Let me define the
following properties.
The first property, I'll
call DISC with epsilon.
So I give you an
explicit parameter.
The number of edges
between x and y
differs from the number of
edges that you would expect.
So as in the expander
mixing lemma.
So the DISC property is that
this quantity is small relative
to the total number of edges.
The second property, which we'll
call the eigenvalue property,
EIG, is that G is an n, d,
lambda graph, with lambda,
at most, epsilon d.
So lambda is quite small
as a function of d.
The conclusion of the
theorem is that, up
to a small change of
parameters, these two properties
are equivalent.
In particular,
eigenvalue implies a--
epsilon implies DISC of epsilon.
And DISC of
epsilon-- and this is
the-- the second one is the
more interesting direction--
it implies EIG.
Well, you lose a
little bit, but,
at most, a constant factor.
EIG of 8 epsilon.
Any questions about
the statement so far?
And so, as I mentioned,
this is completely false
if you consider
non-Cayley graphs.
And we also, using
expander mixing lemma,
using that implication up
there, this direction follows.
One of the main
reasons I want to show
you a proof of this
theorem is that it
uses this tool which I
think is worth knowing.
And this is an important
inequality known
as Grothendieck's inequality.
So many of you probably
know Grothendieck
as this famous French
mathematician who
reinvented modern
algebraic geometry
and spent the rest
of his life writing
tomes and tomes of
text that have yet
to be translated to English.
But he also did some
important foundational work
in functional analysis
before he became
an algebraic geometry nerd.
And this is one of the important
results in that area that he--
so Grothendieck's
inequality tells us
that there exists some
absolute constant k
such that for every matrix A--
so a real-valued matrix--
we have that the--
so we have that, if you--
so here's the idea.
Let's consider the supremum--
so let's consider the
following quantity.
This is a bilinear form.
So this is a bilinear form.
This is basically a--
so bilinear form, if you
hit it by a vector x and y
from the two sides.
And I'm interested in
what is the maximum value
of this bilinear form
if you are allowed
to take x and y to be plus/minus
1-valued real numbers?
So this is an
important quantity,
and it gives you a matrix.
And it's basically asking you,
you get a sign of plus or minus
to each row and
column, and I want
to maximize this number here.
This is an important
quantity that we'll
see actually much more in the
next chapter on graph limits.
But, for now, just take my word.
This is a very
important quantity.
And this is actually
a quantity that
is very difficult to evaluate.
If I give you a
very large matrix
and ask you to compute
this number here,
there is no good
algorithm for it.
And it's believed that there
is no good algorithm for it.
On the other hand,
there is a relaxation
of this problem, which
is the following.
It's still a sum, but now,
instead of considering
the bilinear form there, let's
consider the xi's and yi's.
Not-- take them not form real
numbers, but take vectors.
So let's consider
the sum where I'm
taking a similar-looking sum,
except that xi's and yi's come
from a unit ball in
some vector space
with an inner product,
where B is the unit
ball in some Rm, where here
the dimension is actually not
so relevant.
The dimension is arbitrary.
If you like, you can make
m n or 2n because you only
have that many vectors.
So this quantity here,
just by very definition,
is a relaxation of the
right-hand of this quantity
here.
So it's at least this large.
So, in particular, if you
have whatever plus/minus,
you can always look at the same
quantity with m equal to 1,
and you obtain
this quantity here.
But this quantity may
be substantially larger.
So the x and y's have more
room to put themselves in
to maximize the sum.
And Grothendieck's inequality
tells us that the left-hand
side actually cannot be too
much larger than the right-hand
side.
It exceeds it by, at
most, a constant factor.
So, in other words,
the left-hand side,
which is known as a
semi-definite relaxation,
you are not losing by more
than a constant factor
compared to the
original problem.
And this is important
in computer science
because the left-hand
side turns out
to be a Semidefinite
Program, an SDP, which
does have efficient
algorithms to compute.
So you can give a constant
factor approximation
to this difficult compute
but important quantity
by using semidefinite
relaxation.
And Grothendieck's
inequality promises us
that it is a good relaxation.
You might ask, what
is the value of k?
So I said there exists
some constant k.
So this is actually a mystery.
So the current proofs have
been improved over time.
And Grothendieck himself
proved this theorem,
but it constantly has
been improved over time.
And, currently, the
best-known result
is something along the lines
of k roughly 1.78 works.
But the optimal value, which
is known as Grothendieck's
constant, is unknown.
So this is
Grothendieck's constant.
Actually, this, what
I've written down
is what's called the real
Grothendieck's constant.
Because you can
also write a version
for complex numbers
and complex vectors,
and that's the complex
Grothendieck's constant.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a lower bound that's
known [INAUDIBLE]
greater than 1?
YUFEI ZHAO: Is there a
lower bound that is known?
Yes.
It's known that it's
strictly bigger than 1.
AUDIENCE: Do we
know [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: So there are
some specific numbers,
but I forget what they are.
You can look it up.
Any more questions?
So we'll leave
Grothendieck's inequality.
We'll use it as a black box.
So if you wish to
learn the proof,
I encourage you to do so.
There are some quite
nice proofs out there.
And we'll use it to
prove this theorem here
about quasi-random
Cayley graphs.
So let's suppose DISC holds.
So what would we like to--
what do we like to show?
We want to show that this
eigenvalue condition holds.
And we'll use the--
some min-max characterization
of eigenvalues.
But, first, some preliminaries.
Suppose you have vectors x
and y which have plus/minus 1
coordinate values.
Then, by letting-- so let's
consider the following vectors,
where I split up
x and y according
to where they're positive
and where they're negative.
So, here, these are such
that x plus is equal to--
so if I evaluate it on a
coordinate g, then it's 1.
So if x sub g is plus
1, and 0 otherwise.
xg sub minus is 1 if
x sub g is minus 1.
0 otherwise.
So x splits into x plus
minus x minus, and y splits
into y plus minus y minus.
Let's consider a matrix A
where the g comma h entry of A
is the following quantity.
I have the set S, and I look at
whether g inverse h lies in S.
And I can consider
an indicator of that.
So it's 1 or 0.
And then subtract d over n so
that this value has mean 0.
So this is a matrix.
And now if I consider
the bilinear form,
hit A from left and
right with x and y,
then the bilinear form
splits according to the plus
and minuses of the x's.
And I claim that each
one of these terms
is controlled because of DISC.
So, for example,
the first term is,
if you expand out
what this guy is--
so here's an indicator vector.
That's an indicator vector.
And if you look
at the definition,
then this is precisely the
number of edges between x plus
and y plus minus d
over n times the size
of x plus times
the size of y plus,
where x plus is the
set of group elements
such that x sub g
is 1, and so on.
All right.
So the punchline up there
is that this quantity--
so this quantity is, at most,
by discrepancy, epsilon dn.
So this sum here, by
triangle inequality,
is, at most, 4 epsilon dn.
All right.
So, so far, we've reinterpreted
the discrepancy property.
And what we really want
to show is that this graph
satisfies eigenvalue condition.
So what does that
actually mean to satisfy
the eigenvalue condition?
So by the min-max
characterization
of eigenvalues, it follows
that the maximum of these two
eigenvalues, which is
the quantity that we
would like to control, is
equal to the following.
It is equal to the supremum
of this bilinear form
when x and y are
unit-length vectors.
And this is simply
because A is the matrix--
it's not the adjacency matrix.
A is not the adjacency matrix.
A is the matrix obtained
by essentially taking
the adjacency matrix
and subtracting
that constant there.
And subtracting that constant
gets rid of the top eigenvalue.
And what you remained
is whatever that's left.
And you want to show that
whatever you remained
has small spectral radius.
So we would like to show
that this quantity here
is quite small.
Well, let's do it.
So give me a pair
of vectors, x and y.
And let's set the
following quantities,
where I take a twist
on this x vector
by rotating the
coordinates, setting
x super s sub g, the
coordinate g, to be x sub sg.
So x is a vector indexed
by the group elements,
and then rotating this indexing
of the group elements by s.
So that's what I mean
by superscript s.
And, likewise, y superscript
s is defined similarly.
So I claim that these
twists, these rotations,
do not change the
norm of these vectors.
And that should be pretty
clear, because I'm simply
relabeling the coordinates
in a uniform way.
And, likewise, same for y.
So I would like to show this
quantity up here is small.
So let's consider
two unit vectors.
And consider this bilinear form.
If I expand out this bilinear
form, it looks like that.
I'm just writing it out.
But now let me just throw in
an extra variable of summation.
What we'll do is essentially
look at the same sum,
but now I add in an extra
s, and put this s over here.
So convince yourself that
this is the same sum.
So it's simply
re-parameterizing the sum.
So this is the same sum.
But now, if you look
at the definition of A,
there's this cancellation.
So the two s's cancel out.
So let's rewrite the sum.
1 over n, then g, h,
s, all group elements.
Then-- now, if I bring
this summation of s,
now I bring it inside, and then
you see that what's inside is
simply the inner product between
the two vectors, x sub g--
between the two vectors.
So this is-- so what's
inside is simply
the product, inner
product, between these two.
So I may need to redefine.
Yes.
So when you're looking
at-- when you're
talking about
non-Abelian groups,
it's always a
question of which side
should you multiply things by.
And you guys are OK?
Or I need to change
this s to over here.
But anyway, it should work.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: yh [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: yh.
Thank you.
Yes, I think--
OK.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
So maybe I need to switch
the definition here,
but, in any case, some
version of this should be OK.
Yes.
So figure it out
later in the notes.
But now-- OK.
So you have this--
we have this here.
And if you look at
this quantity here,
it is the kind of
quantity that comes up
in Grothendieck's inequality.
So this is basically
the left-hand side
of Grothendieck's inequality.
What about the right-hand side
of Grothendieck's inequality?
Well, we already
controlled that.
We already controlled
that because we
said, whenever you have up
there little x and little y--
so the conclusion of
this board was that--
let me erase over here.
So the conclusion of this board
was that this bilinear form
is bounded by, at
most, 4 epsilon d,
for all x and y being
plus/minus 1 coordinate valued.
So combining them
by Grothendieck,
we have an upper bound, which is
the Grothendieck constant times
4 epsilon--
so 4 epsilon dn.
There's a-- sorry.
There's an n missing here.
And, therefore, because
the Grothendieck constant
is less than 2, we have
a bound of 8 epsilon d.
And this shows that this
variational problem, which
characterizes the largest
eigenvalue in absolute value,
is, at most, 8
epsilon d, thereby
implying the
eigenvalue property.
So the main takeaway from
this proof, two things.
One is Grothendieck's inequality
is a nice thing to know.
So it's a semidefinite
relaxation
that changes the problem,
which is initially somewhat
intractable, to a
semidefinite problem which
is both, from a computer
science point of view,
algorithmically
tractable, but also has
nice mathematical properties.
And for this application
here, there's
this nice trick in
this proof where
I'm symmetrizing the coordinates
using the group symmetries.
And that allows me to obtain
this characterization showing
that eigenvalue condition and
this discrepancy condition
are equivalent
for Cayley graphs.
Let's take a quick break.
Any questions so far?
So we've been talking
about n, d, lambda graphs.
So d regular graphs.
And the next question
I would like to address
is, In an n, d, lambda graph,
how small can lambda be?
So smaller lambda corresponds
to a more pseudorandom graph.
So how small can this be?
And the right kind of setting
that I want you to think about
is think of d as a constant.
So think of d as a constant,
and n getting large.
So how small can lambda be.
And it turns out there is a
limit to how small it can be.
And it is known as the
Alon-Boppana bound,
which tells you that
if you have a fixed d--
and so G is an n-vertex
graph with adjacency matrix
eigenvalues lambda
1 through lambda n,
sorted in non-increasing order.
Then the second largest
eigenvalue has to be at least,
basically, 2 root d minus
1 minus a small error term,
little on--
little o1, where the
little o1 goes to 0 as n
goes to infinity.
So the Alon-Boppana bound tells
you that the lambda cannot be
below this quantity here.
And I want to explain
what is the significance
of this quantity, and you
will see it in the proof.
And this quantity is
the best possible.
And it also says what do we know
about the existence of graphs
which have lambda 2
close to this number.
So this is the optimal
number you can put here.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Does it say
anything about how
negative lambda n can be?
YUFEI ZHAO:
Question-- does it say
how negative lambda n can be?
So I'll address
that in a second,
but, essentially, if you have
a bipartite graph and lambda
n equals to minus lambda 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: More questions?
So I want to show you a
proof and, time permitting,
a couple of proofs of
Alon-Boppana bound.
And they're all quite
simple to execute, but the--
I think it's a good
way to understand how
these special techniques work.
So, first, as with all of the
proofs that we did concerning--
or most of them--
concerning eigenvalues,
we're looking
at the Courant-Fischer
characterization
of eigenvalues.
It suffices to show, to
exhibit some vector z--
so a nonzero vector--
such that z is orthogonal
to the all 1's vector
and this quotient is at
least the claimed bound.
So by the Courant-Fischer
characterization
of the second
eigenvalue, if you vary
over all such d that are
orthogonal to the unit
vector, then the maximum
value this quantity attains
is equal to lambda 2.
So to show the
lambda 2 is large,
it suffices to exhibit such a z.
So let me construct
such a z for you.
So let r be a positive integer.
And let's pick an
arbitrary vertex v. So v
is a vertex in the graph.
And let V sub i denote vertices
at distance exactly i from V.
From-- yes, from V. So, in
particular, V0 is equal to V--
and I can just
draw you a picture.
So you have V0, and then
the neighbors of V0,
and each of them
have more neighbors.
Like that.
So I'm calling V0
this stuff, big V0.
And then big V1, V
sub 2, and so on.
So I'm going to define a
vector, which I'll eventually
make into z, by
telling you what is
the value of this vector
on each of these vertices.
I will do this by
setting very explicitly--
so set x to be a
vector with value
x sub u to be wi, where wi
is d minus 1 raised to power
minus i over 2 whenever u
lies in set big V sub i.
So u is distance exactly i from
V. I set it to this number.
So notice that they decrease
as you get further away from V.
And I do this for all
distances less than r.
So this is my x vector.
And I set all the other
vect-- all the other corners
to be 0 if the distance
between u and V is at least r.
So that gives you this vector.
And I would like to compute
that quotient over there
for this vector.
And I claim that this
quotient here is at least
the following quantity.
But this is a computation,
so let's just do it.
So why is this true?
Well, if you compute
the norm of x--
so I'm just taking
the sum of the squares
of these coordinates.
Well, that comes from
adding up these values.
So for each element in
the i-th neighborhood.
So I have wi squared.
And if I look at that quantity
up there, so what is this?
A is the adjacency matrix.
So over here, A is
the adjacency matrix.
So this quantity, I can write
it as a sum over all vertices u.
And I look at x sub
u, and now I sum again
over all neighbors of u,
and consider x sub u prime.
It's that sum there.
But this sum, I have some
control over, because it is--
so what's happening here?
I claim it has at least
the following quantity.
Consider where u is.
So u could be--
I mean, it's only
nonzero if u lies
in the r minus 1th neighborhood.
So in that neighborhood, I
have V sub i possible choices
for the vertex u.
For that choice, this
x sub u is w sub i.
But what about
all its neighbors?
So it could have
neighbors, well,
in the same set going left.
But there's-- so there's
one neighbor going left,
and all the other
neighbors are--
maybe it's in the same set,
maybe it's in the next set.
But, in any case, I have
the following inequality.
There's one neighbor
in the same--
in the left, if you look
at that picture just now.
And then all the
remaining neighbors
have x sub u primes at
least w sub i plus 1,
because these weights
are decreasing.
So I can-- the worst
case, so to speak,
is if you-- all the neighbors
point to the next set.
So I had that inequality there.
There's an issue.
Because if you go to
the very last set,
if you go to the very
last set and think
about what happens, when i
in in that very last set,
I'm overcounting neighbors
that no longer has weights.
So I need to take them out.
So I should subtract
d minus 1 times--
and so this is the
maximum possible weight
sum I could have--
maximum possible overcount.
So each product here has t
minus 1 neighbors at most.
All right.
So this is-- should be
pretty straightforward if you
do the counting correctly.
But now let's plug in
what these weights are.
And you'll find that this
sum here, this quantity,
is equal to-- so
the key point here
is that this thing simplifies
very nicely if you consider
what this is.
So what ends up
happening is that you
get this extra factor
of 2 root d minus 1.
And then the sum minus
1/2 of V sub [INAUDIBLE]..
It's pretty
straightforward computation
using the specific
weights that we have.
And one more thing is
that notice that this--
so notice that the sizes of
each neighborhood cannot expand
by more than a factor of
d minus 1, because, well,
you only have d minus 1 outward
edges going forward at each
step.
And, as a result, I
can bound this guy.
And so what you find is
that this whole thing here
is that least 2
times root d minus 1.
The main term is the sum.
And this here is less than
each individual summand.
So I can do 1 minus 1 over 2r.
Putting these two together,
you find the claim.
All right.
So I've exhibited
this vector x, which
has that quotient property.
But that's not quite enough,
because we need a vector--
so it's called z up here--
that is orthogonal to
the all 1's vector.
And that you can do, because
if the number of vertices
is quite a bit larger than--
compared to the degree, then I
claim that there exists u and v
vectors--
vertices that are at
distance at least 2r.
So if I let--
this is the size of this tree.
So if you have--
everything is
within distance r--
distance 2r from a vertex, then
they all lie on this tree edge.
If you count the number
of vertices in that tree,
it's what I have-- the
sum I've written here.
So if I consider
these two vectors--
so be-- so x be the vector
obtained above, which is,
in some sense--
and I'm being somewhat
informal here-- centered at v.
And if I let y be the vector but
I center it now at the vector--
at u, then I claim that,
essentially, x and y
are supported on disjoint
vertex sets that have
no edges even between them.
So, in particular,
this inner product--
this bilinear form-- not inner
product but this bilinear
form--
is equal to 0, since no edge
between the supports of x
and y.
So now I have two vectors
that do not interact,
but both have this
nice property above.
And now I can take a
linear combination.
Let me choose a constant c--
so it's a real constant--
such that this z equal
to x minus cy has--
and I can choose this constant.
So x and y are both
non-negative entries.
They're both nonzero, and I
can choose this constant c
so that it is--
this z is orthogonal
to the all 1's vector.
And I now I have this
extra property I want.
But what about the
inner products?
Well, these two vectors, x and
y, they do not interact at all.
So their inner products
split just fine,
and the bilinear form
splits just fine.
So you have this inequality
here, as desired.
And r, notice that
I can take r going
to infinity as n going to
infinity, because d is fixed.
So if n goes to infinity, then
r can go to infinity, roughly
a logarithmic n.
And that proves the
Alon-Boppana bound.
And just to recap,
to prove this bound,
we needed to exhibit by the
Courant-Fischer some vector
with a nice--
this quotient such that
this quotient is large.
And we exhibit this quotient
by constructing the vector
explicitly around the vertex and
finding two such vertices that
are far away from constructing
these two vectors,
taking the appropriate
linear combination
so that the final vector is
orthogonal to the unit vector,
to the all 1's vector,
and then showing
that the corresponding bilinear
form has-- is large enough.
Any questions?
I want to show you a different
proof which gives you
a slightly worse result, but
the proof is conceptually nice.
So let me give you
a second proof which
is slightly weakening.
And just that we'll show--
so we'll show that--
so the earlier proof showed
that lambda 2 is quite large.
But, next, we'll show that the
max of lambda 2 and the lambda
n is large.
So not that the second
largest eigenvalue is large,
but the second largest
eigenvalue in absolute value
is large.
So it's slightly weaker, but,
for all intents and purposes,
it's the same spirit.
So I'll show this one here.
And this is a nice
illustration of what's
called a trace method,
sometimes also a moment method.
Here's the idea.
As we saw in the proof relating
the quasi-randomness of C4
and eigenvalues,
well, C4's are--
eigenvalues are related
to counting closed walks
in a graph.
And so we'll use that counting
closed walks in a graph.
And, specifically, the
2k-th moment of the spectrum
is equal to the trace of
the 2k-th power, which
counts the number of closed
walks of length exactly 2k.
So to lower bound
the left-hand side,
we want to lower-bound
the right-hand side.
So let's consider closed walks
starting at a fixed vertex.
So the number of
closed walks of length
exactly 2k starting at
a fixed vertex v. Here
we're in a d regular graph.
So here we are in
a d regular graph.
I claim, whatever this number
is-- it maybe different
for each d-- it is at least
the same quantity if I
do this walk in an
infinite d regular tree.
So infinite d
regular tree is what?
This is an infinite
d regulator tree.
We just start with the
vertex, and go out d regular.
So why is this true?
So think about how you walk.
So let me just explain.
This is, I think,
pretty easy once you
see things the right way.
So start with a vertex v.
Think about how you walk.
And whatever way you
can walk, well, you
can walk the same way on
the infinite d regular tree.
Well, I mean, sorry.
Whatever walk you can do
an infinite d regular tree,
if you label the first vertex,
the first edge, second edge,
if you do a
corresponding labeling
on your original
graph, you can do
that walk on your
original graph.
Although the original graph
may have some additional walks,
namely things that
involve cycles,
that are not available
on your tree.
But, certainly, every
walk, you can do.
Every closed walk
you can do on a tree,
you can do the same
walk on your graph.
So you can make
this more formal.
So you can write down a
bijection or injection
to make this more formal, but
it should be fairly convincing
that this inequality is true.
But this is just a number.
So this is a number of 2k walks
in a d regular tree starting
on the vertex.
And this number has
been well studied,
and we don't need to
know the precise number.
We just need to know
some good lower bound.
And here is one lower bound,
which is that there's at least
a Catalan number, the
k-th Catalan number,
times d minus 1 to the k, where
C sub k is the k-th Catalan
number, which is equal to--
so k 2k choose k
divided by k plus 1.
So let me remind
you what this is.
A wonder, has many
combinatorial interpretations,
and it's a fun exercise to
do bijections between them.
But, in particular,
C3 is the equal to 5,
which counts the number of
ups and down walks of length
6 that never dip below
the horizontal line
where you start.
So, then, this
corresponds to going away
from the root versus
coming back to the root.
Soon you have at
least that many ways.
And when you are moving
away from the root,
you have d minus 1 choices
on which branch to go to.
OK, good.
Given that, the right-hand
side is at least, then,
n, the number of vertices,
times the quantity above related
to Catalan numbers.
On the other hand, the
left-hand side is at most--
here we're using that
2k is an even number--
is at most d to the 2k plus all
the other eigenvalues that are
most lambda in absolute value.
So let me call this
quantity lambda.
Rearranging this inequality,
we find that lambda to the 2k
is at least this number here.
Just here, I'm changing
n minus 1 to n.
So we have that.
And now what can we do?
We let n go to infinity and k
go to infinity slowly enough.
So if k goes to
infinity and n goes to--
so k goes to infinity with
n, but not too quickly.
But k is little of log n.
And we find that
this quantity here
is essentially 2 to the k--
2 to the 2k.
And this guy here is little o1.
So lambda is at least 2 root
d minus 1 minus little o1.
That proves, essentially,
the Alon-Boppana bound,
although a small
weakening because we are--
this big eigenvalue,
you might find
might actually be very negative
instead of very positive.
But that's OK.
For applications, this
is not such a big deal.
These are two different proofs.
And now, we think about, are
they really the same proof?
Are they different proofs?
Are they related to each other?
So it's worth thinking about.
They look very
different, but how
are they related to each other?
And one final remark.
You already saw two
different proofs as to--
I mean, that shows
you this number,
and you see where this
number comes from.
And let me just offer
one final remark on where
that number really comes from.
And it really comes from
this infinite d regular tree.
So it turns out that
2 root d minus 1
exactly is the spectral radius
of the infinite d regular tree.
And that is the
reason, in some sense,
that this is the correct number
occurring Alon-Boppana bound.
This is-- if you've seen
things like algebraic topology
or topology, this is a universal
cover for d regular graphs.
So I won't talk more about it,
but just some general remarks,
and you already saw
two different proofs.
So beginning of next time,
I want to wrap this up
and to show you--
to explain some--
what we know about
are there graphs for
which this bound is tight?
And the answer is yes, and there
are lots of major open problems
as well related to
what happens there.
And then, after
that, I would like
to start talking
about graph limits.
So that's the next
chapter of this course.
OK, good.